I often make about 20 deliveries a day...
...so it's crucial I can get around quickly...
...and not get stuck in traffic.
That's why we have yellow box junctions.
The purpose of these are to keep road space free for road users like Anthony.
So, how do you use a yellow box junction?
You may enter a yellow box junction when your exit is clear...
...and there is enough space on the other side of the junction...
...for your vehicle to clear the box without stopping.
You can only stop in a yellow box junction when turning right...
...and are prevented from doing so by oncoming traffic...
...or by other vehicles waiting to turn right.
If your exit isn't clear and you're not turning right,...
...no part of your vehicle should be in the box.
Then, as soon as you're sure it's safe, you can proceed.
Remember, blocking the yellow box junction...
...means everyone else gets stuck with you.
Yellow box junctions are here to keep the traffic flowing.
If everyone did their bit and followed the simple rules,...
...London would be an easier place to get around.